ah
[Applause]
it was an amazing feeling to look around
yellowdragon Stadium and see that our
team had grown to fill 16,000 seats it
was hard to believe that this was the
same Chinese Internet company I joined
10 years earlier just as it moved out of
a small apartment and leading us through
our improbable journey was this former
English teacher Jack Ma in 1999 he and
17 friends had started Alibaba calm in
his apartment I greeted Jack as he
walked in I had worked as a vice
president in his company for nearly 10
years
as our team survived the internet bubble
fought a war with eBay and managed to
build China's first global Internet
company I settled into my seat and
wondered how would Jack address us on
this important night and then just like
any other billionaire in the same
situation Jack took the stage
[Applause]
well it may not have been typical for a
company chairman but it wasn't
surprising coming from Jack people
outside the company assumed he was crazy
but those of us inside the company knew
better